my best friend is a boy
we had this brilliant idea let's get a
place together
my dad's not cool with it human nature
is like if they're living together
they're going to hook up sexually
[Music]
my name is rihanna i'm 20 years old i'm
gabriella
i'm 20 years old my name is i'm 14. and
i'm really excited to have this
conversation with my dad today i'm
pretty excited to talk to my dad about
certain things
deep conversations uh i feel a little
bit nervous to talk to my dad today
my relationship with my dad is
good we've been through a lot of stuff
together he raised me on his own with no
mom
so that has definitely built us stronger
together
[Music]
my name is benjamin and i'm the father
of one
beautiful and infinitely talented and
loving 14 year old young lady
my name is mike i'm a father of three
girls
hi my name is brian i'm a father of two
once you became a dad what was your
biggest lesson
that it's the true meaning of our
existence that's the thing i wanted
most in my entire life is to be a father
and
it's everything i've ever expected
i'm gabriella and this is my dad mike
i'm mike and this is my daughter
gabriella
my name is benjamin and this is my
beautiful daughter si lally
my name is c lally and my dad is
benjamin
hi i'm rihanna this is my dad brian
this is my daughter rihanna daughters
please go to the left
fathers please go to the right
step forward if you agree with the
statement
daughters must be raised differently
than sons
it's not so much because of them but
because of the society we live in
but i know if i had a 14 year old boy
and
i wanted to send them out to the corner
store i would feel pretty confident in
doing that
but for my daughter it's a different
situation and it's not her fault
it's because of society like i said i
agree right where i have to be
more careful she's very strong and
capable of you know
defending herself in a lot of ways but
at the end of the day she's not as big
as strong as a dude
yeah and i'm going to worry about that
so because of that i feel i have to be
more protective of her i agree and
defend her
i agree is exactly the same thing
so i don't have a son i only have
daughters
but if i had a son i don't think i would
raise him any differently
the type of scenario that you're talking
about i completely agree
but i think is i think this world is
dangerous for both male and female
one time i was in the eighth grade and i
guess i didn't tell my dad i was going
to city walk with my friends and i
didn't come home
till like midnight or 11 pm and the cops
were like
all over my block i dialed 9-1-1 i said
my daughter's gone i know where she's at
she doesn't answer her phone if i was my
brother because he's three years older
than me so at the time i was like 14
he'd be 17 my dad would be liking
whatever you know if he calls me calls
me but if it's me it's like oh my god
my daughter is missing i think he can be
a little overprotective when it comes to
like having friends that are guys
i think he assumes a lot and i think he
should just
assume the best not the worst me too
just a cool friendship
there are no guy friends no i'm just
kidding i wouldn't like i wouldn't let
any boys in our apartment burbank
especially not in your bedroom you know
my best friend is a boy
we're very very very close and we're
both
in between housing situations right now
for when we go back to college
we had this brilliant idea let's get a
place together we're best friends we
hang out
24 7. my dad's not cool with it i'm just
not gonna challenge it because
no reason to why aren't you cool with it
if you don't mind me asking
because i think there's a place in the
time for everything and i don't think
that i'm ready for her to move in with
a guy that i don't know and you know
human nature is like if they're living
together
they're gonna hook up sexually
[Laughter]
like there's no way ever
can i ask you this um let's say you're
20 right 20 years old
say you had a 20 year old son and he was
in a living situation
where you want to have a female roommate
i think the answer to him
i think the answer is obvious okay
because
as you said now i'm gonna go back to
agreeing with you that you have to treat
it a little differently but i think if i
had a son and he was 20 and he would
want to live
with a girl i wouldn't have any
objection would you find it weird if you
had a son
and he was 20 and he wanted to live with
a girl and there was nothing romantic
there at all
no i wouldn't find it weird i know how
guys are you know when they're young
they got a lot of testosterone and girls
like to tease
it's dangerous for chicks i mean they
got to really watch their stuff
but what if we're just sitting down and
we look good is that still teasing
someone
you can't it can be it depends on what
you're doing but i feel like girls don't
even try doing it intentional sometimes
people are just good at looking
if you raise them equally then they'll
learn
and grow up to see each other as equals
instead of like
having like misogyny and stuff like that
i completely agree with that
me too blaming the girls kind of puts
the onus on the girls
to stop that gross behavior when the
onus is on
the boys and the people who are raising
them and the media that they're watching
what would you say is the biggest
challenge for you too
probably something like communication
and just understanding
how i feel and sometimes that i
don't agree with things that he thinks
recently
i decided i wanted to live with my mom
because
i just get a lot of intense anxiety
around him and
it might be a little awkward
i struggled to communicate my feelings
to my family
a lot of the times i just don't know how
my dad will react
to some of my feelings and i just don't
want
i don't like for him to see me upset
because i know it upsets him a lot i do
remember very vividly one time him
telling me
that whatever my energy is
he's gonna put the same energy back i
remember he told me that one time and it
kind of just
stuck with me and i always think about
it so i'm always thinking
how do what do i say how do i put myself
like
when i'm angry and stuff
i feel that i've been a very open father
and understanding
and i try to let her know that i'm not
going to judge her i'm not here to judge
her i'm here to help her
i definitely feel that she doesn't feel
comfortable expressing herself to me
fully and it's so strange you know
because
we grew up so close we grew up so close
we were together all the time
i feel like when she became a teenager
it was like all that changed
everything it was like alternate
universe like what is this what is going
on
you just have to give her some space
definitely
i don't know i guess uh it scares me a
lot to disappoint him
that makes sense but just know that
you're never gonna disappoint me
like nothing you do will ever disappoint
me i love you infinitely for who you are
and i accept you fully for who you are
i love you unconditionally okay
sorry it's okay love it's okay
yeah it's totally okay you don't
disappoint me you never will
i didn't really have my mom to run to
when i started my period like all the
girl things
literally like yeah i see my mom here
and there but my dad
took custody me at such a young age so
that made us like have a really strong
relationship he's also like my best
friend i tell him everything i tell him
who i'm dating this and that and the
cool thing is about him is like
dads could be like don't do this don't
do that but if anything he just gives me
really good advice
that's really sweet she hides about 20
percent of stuff for me and i had about
from her she doesn't tell me everything
because i don't want to know too much
you know
so i i went through a lot of mental
health stuff and physical health stuff
in the last two years
when i was 18 i wasn't ready to say
anything to anybody i'm a very private
person and my dad is too so he
understands and he never
he never pried and he never asked too
many questions and i like to keep
everything that was going on
to myself because otherwise it felt like
i was
including more people into my problem
and the second time was kind of when it
hit me like
i can't do this alone and i need my
biggest support system to be there for
me and
it's always going to be my parents
especially my dad
we went through this together i mean she
had to go through this we i was there
just to support her and so so
was her mom but he definitely made our
relationship so much stronger
i mean i i i wouldn't have it any other
way
nobody wants to be vulnerable in front
of their family but you know if you're
vulner if you get sick
their your kids are there to take care
of you when i broke my health broke down
i'm on kidney dialysis she takes me to
dialysis three times a week
she feeds me i just go agree and i'm
hungry i feel like my dad takes care of
me by paying my rent paying my car
insurance getting me
anything i need so the least i could do
for him when his health isn't good is
take care of him
so my grandpa died five years ago my dad
went to go
be in israel say goodbye to his dad
spend time with his family
but my dad was there for a month and we
didn't see him for that month
and i realized a couple years later that
he went so he wouldn't have to grieve in
front of us
it just made me sad that he felt like he
couldn't do that and now i understand
why
i know that i'm the backbone of the
family and i like
and i'm the only man of the house so i
wouldn't want to see myself breaking
down in front of anyone of my family
i don't think there was a situation that
i needed to
but i i wouldn't think that i'd be
comfortable opening up that much
i feel similar i feel like i have to be
strong just because i can't
show her what i'm going through because
then i'm kind of putting her through it
similar to what you said
you know just recently she made a big
decision she decided that she wanted to
stay with her mom full time
since she was two years old we've always
shared custody 50 50 down the middle
so i went from seeing her half of the
time to
here and there and it hurt me hurt me a
lot it hurt me down to my core
but at the end of the day that was her
decision and she thought it was best for
her mental health
so i agreed with it but i can't sit here
and say that night i didn't go home and
cry
you know but obviously that's not
something i want her to see because
i want her to be happy regardless of
anything
raising a 14 year old young lady being a
man myself
there's a bit of a disconnect and in
this world of
social media and instant gratifications
and
all these things that we have to deal
with it's the biggest challenge i've
ever had
i have had moments i felt like i failed
my family
my hospitalizations have
put some financial strain on my family
and they've taken a huge emotional toll
on my family
my parents and my sisters and the first
time it was like
yeah this is horrible but we have to get
through it
and the second time i just kept saying
to myself
i can't believe i let this happen again
i can't believe i'm back here
and i can't believe i'm doing this to my
family all over again
i'm really insecure about things that i
do and just myself in general
so i constantly feel like i'm such a
disappointment to
especially my dad
well the question was if you feel you
failed or
disappointed your family i i don't i
mean
why why do you i don't think i
disappointed you
i just feel if i had been a little bit
more diligent
i wouldn't have found myself in the
position that i was in in august
yeah but you also have to remember that
you were fighting and it was a little
stronger than
than you and eventually took over and we
needed to fight back and we fought back
and we won it but you definitely
did not disappoint us or failed us in
any way that's absolutely not the case
my angel i tried to get her
you know through my lawyer and the judge
just blew me away
and i told last thing i told the judge
was you know the police told me a long
time ago if they keep coming out
somebody's going to go to jail
and they they had been out between her
and her mother having fist fights and
she was just a kid
i really just needed to get out of that
situation it was just bad for me health
wise to be with my mom i mean i love her
she's my mom we're okay now because
we're away
your part because we're apart but living
with her is a different story when you
live with someone it's
different my dad at the time it was such
a coincidence because i
was like i just need to get out of here
she hit me in my face at that moment i
had a bloody nose
and my dad specifically that time got
off work like three hours early
and he opened the door and he saw me and
she went to jail
and ever since he's had custody of me
wow
you know i think i probably should have
sat down in the filled your family
because
in some ways i do feel that i did fail
you and in the way that i filled you was
setting those expectations on you you
know when she was born i
i wanted her to be so perfect i put her
in gymnastics
i taught her multiple languages if she
was in a very specific school that she
went to
and i feel like me having those thoughts
and those ideas of what a perfect
daughter would be put too much pressure
definitely
and at the end of the day that's my
fault so i understand why she feels the
way you do but i am sorry i apologize to
you
forever putting those expectations on
you you're great just the way you are
and i'm just happy that we're here we're
having this moment
you know i told my dad that we were
doing this video he had no idea what was
going on and i'm just grateful that he
trusted me enough to just come no
questions asked if it wasn't for you
i would not be the strong person i am
the outspoken person i am or the
opinionated person i am
i wouldn't have zero tolerance for
[ __ ]
and it's all because of you that i'm
able to
live my life in the strongest way i
possibly can
i'm gonna repeat something you said
because i found it beautiful and i
completely agree with you but
there's nothing in this world that you
could ever do that would disappoint me
what i feel towards you and your sisters
is just
endless love and nothing can ever change
that
i just want to say that i'm thankful
that i have a dad
that loves me unconditionally
and obviously saved me from
an abusive relationship with my mother
because if i didn't have a dad
and i was living with my mother i don't
know where i would be right now so
i'm happy and thankful i have him she's
a lovely kid and she's
actually my caregiver you know right now
she's not working and she runs all my
urns she takes me everywhere i want to
go and does everything for me so i'm
very proud to have her as a daughter
i guess i feel like you kind of made me
strong
so thank you a lot for that
and i love you a lot too
[Music]
you